girls education is under attack in Iran
a number of incidents have been reported
across various parts of the country
where girls in classrooms say they
become ill after inhaling a what they
believe to be a suspicious poisonous gas
that is being fed into the classrooms
the girls saying that they become dizzy
nauseous some of them are not able to
move their limbs they fall down after
inhaling these suspicious gas substance
that have been released into various
schools there's now according to
officials over 1200 schoolgirls who have
become ill over the past three months
officials now very much involved in this
taking it very seriously or parents are
very very angry the incidents have
mainly occurred in various parts of the
capital in the suburbs of Tehran as well
as the holy city of Gom where there have
been multiple incidents reported since
last November this is something that is
very much causing alarm amongst parents
across the country who believe that the
perpetrators of these attacks are those
who believe girls should not receive an
education
foreign